our next guest is Pulitzer prize-winning
journalist Nicole Hannah Jones thank you
very much she covers civil rights and
racial Injustice for the New York Times
magazine her landmark's 1619 project
aimed to re-examine American slavery and
its impact on the systems and the
policies that still shape our country
today she's now expanding that into a
new six-part docu-series it's on Hulu
it's called the 1619 project Nicole
Hannah Jones is host and executive
producer now this clip is from episode
number three examines the history of
blackface
the origins of blackface aren't really
known but the myth goes that a man named
Thomas rice saw an older black man
grooming a horse while singing and
dancing and a light bulb went off
he goes out on stage and performs for a
packed House of people
and a blackface he paints his face black
and he sings a song that is essentially
mentioning this new character that he
invents named Jim Crow the original
appropriation
I can tear it about and you just know
every time I wheel about a jump Jim Crow
the original appropriate Nicole Hannah
Jones joins us at the table that's
Hannah Nicole really good to have you
here that's from episode three music
you've got six different categories
democracy race music capitalism fear and
Justice I want to start with uh episode
number two about race because that was
so fascinating to me because it's such a
personal project you are biracial you
talk about having a white mother and a
black father but what got me is a
conversation you had with your daughter
who was also very curious about
questions about her own background can
you just share that conversation that
you had with your daughter sure thank
you so much for having me on to talk
about the documentary Series so you know
that conversation really tries to get at
we we all hear that race is a political
or social construct but we kind of
believe that it's a real thing yes so um
my we we've accepted the the myth of
racial categorization so my daughter you
know my mother is white my daughter is
the same complexion as I am and we tell
kids that race is about your skin color
well she's looking at our skin color and
she's like well if your mom is white and
our skin looks like hers why are we
white I'm like well we're just not
because my dad is black and that makes
me black and she's like well why yes and
even someone who studies race for a
living it's a hard answer to explain to
a child because I mean there is no real
reason except we have a society that
says that that's so you actually said I
don't know because you said your own
father told you you can never be white
that you will always be black he was a
little kid yeah so when my sisters and I
were growing up my father wanted it to
be clear your mother is white half of
your family is white but you won't go in
the world and be treated like you're
white you'll be treated like a black
child and that's what you are and of
course this is the lesson that that I
then have to pass on to my own child
because what he was doing was preparing
us for the world that we were going to
live then when when your daughter is
taught about history and about race
about slavery in school
how do you want her to be taught the
subject and you are part of that
conversation because people uh have used
your work in schools and as a country
we're trying to wrestle with how do we
talk about the ugliness honestly
confronted in reality and not deepen
these myths of racial categorization
that you point out yes so as you can
imagine in my household we've talked
about these things for a very long time
my daughter had her first book on
slavery when she was three years old
because I felt as a parent that I needed
to prepare her for the world and teach
her this history before she learned it
in school so that I could be shaping her
understanding of her world and her place
in it and the thing is
um our children are going into a world
that's already sending them messages
about race and so we think we might be
protecting them by not teaching them
this history but actually we're not
because they're getting those messages
and they don't have no explanation for
why their world looks like it looks
right my we live in a black neighborhood
my daughter goes to a black school she
sees how housing is different depending
on who lives in in the neighborhood
she's being treated a certain way when
she goes out into the public so to me
our job as both parent and parents and
Educators is to try to be truthful
history is complicated men can do great
things as our Founders did and they can
do really terrible things both can be
true both are true yes and children
actually get that they understand it
Nicole as I watched it last night it
felt like an education to me but then I
thought about where I grew up in
Louisiana and there are people I love
people I'm related to who might watch
that and say this is making me feel bad
about being white what do you say to
people who think that well one what I
what I hope people take away from the
documentary is that the legacy of
slavery is shaping all of our Lives no
matter our race right the capitalism
episode shows how there are millions of
white workers who also are struggling to
pay their bills because of an economy
built on the exploitation of Labor
nothing in this documentary should make
someone feel individually bad but I
think it's okay for us to have a
collective Shame about this part of our
history for us to say we did some
terrible things as a country because
when you own that then you try to do
something better right you try to
address this past so nothing about this
documentary is about
um putting individual blame for peop on
people for things that they haven't
personally done but it certainly is
saying that if you want to collectively
take on the idea that the American
Revolution was fought for these great
ideals that the Declaration is one of
the most important documents in the
world and you also have to take on the
fact that the man who wrote that
enslaved human beings we have to own all
of our history not just the parts that
make us feel good yeah I think people
will get something out of every episode
you learn something honestly from every
single episode what do you hope that
people will come away with when they
watch it black and white because they
might not have read the book they might
not have had the New York Magazine that
I still have but they will watch this
what do you want them to take away from
but I hope people will take away is that
this past this Legacy of slavery which
is a foundational American institution
it's shaping our society whether we
acknowledge it or not people will learn
so many new things in every episode but
also see how that pass is shaping our
presence so to me we can try to hide
from it as we have but we have a country
that is very polarized because we
haven't dealt with it right Nicole
Hannah Jones Bravo to you again new
episodes of the 1619 project are
available Thursdays on Hulu